voulu être un artiste
le blues du businessman un garçon pas
comme les autres quand on arrive en
ville toutes les chansons de Starmania
sont devenues des méga succès pas
étonnant que 4 décennies plus tard cette
nouvelle version de l'Opéra Rock
suscitant en France un véritable
engouement le clamant dent était à Paris
pour l'avant-première de son bébé
version 2022 un bah ouais c'est sa
rajeunit
moi je me donne
je dirais j'ai jamais pensé que cette
harmonie
vieillissait mais
[Musique]
la mise en scène a été confiée au
talentueux Thomas jolie celui qui sera
le chef d'orchestre de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux olympiques de Paris
en 2024 son objectif mettre en valeur
l'histoire des habitants de Monopolis
m'était rendu compte que les chansons
elles avaient pris toute la place et
elles étaient légendaire elles sont
légendaires et elles avaient pris
surtout la place sur l'histoire je pense
que c'est une histoire qui est quand
même très
stupéfiante d'actualité qui continue de
nous parler très fortement
la mise en scène de cette nouvelle
mouture de Starmania et époustouflante
j'ai créé une cage de lumière dans
laquelle sont enfermés les personnages
piégés même les personnages sont piégés
à l'intérieur parce que la lumière les
attire mais c'est aussi la lumière qui
les condamne c'est toute l'histoire de
Starmania
et 40 ans plus tard les textes de
leclamant dent paraissent presque
prophétiques sur scène des jeunes
chanteurs comme William Cloutier qui
n'étaient pas nés lorsque cet opéra rock
a été écrit c'est un peu prémonitoire ce
qui a écrit Luc et Michel c'est à dire
que eux ils ont fait une vision
futuriste du pire il y a beaucoup de
choses malheureusement qui se sont
produites
[Musique]
la distribution compte 4 québécois dont
Gabriel Lapointe 19 ans qui reprend le
rôle des cristal créé à l'époque pour
France Gall de pouvoir effectivement
jouer dans Starmania c'est incroyable de
d'incarner un premier rôle dans cette
opéra rock qui a un message un message
toujours d'actualité ce qui fait à quel
point cette cette opéra Rocket
incroyable
David Latulippe qui interprète zéro
janvier réalise un rêve en participant à
cette méga production et c'est le fun
qu'il y a des Québécois c'est le fun que
ça garde l'esprit de la première version
79 il y avait des Québécois ça tout le
temps était un beau mix
[Musique]
ils sont bien conscients que cette
expérience pourrait changer leur vie et
lancer leur carrière internationale ce
qui réjouit Manet Myriam bagdassariam
qui interprète Sadia Starmania déjà
cette c'est pas juste le spectacle c'est
vraiment une monument ça a changé
beaucoup de vie dans le passé donc ça ça
change beaucoup de vie à tous les jours
avec la musique et tout d'Harmonia
prendre officiellement la fiche en
France le 8 novembre il pourrait bien
être présenté au Québec l'an prochain
ici Nadia Alexandre Chartier
Radio-Canada Paris
[Musique]